bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
première vidéo de sciences étonnante
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous raconter
pourquoi dans n'importe quelle verre
d'eau on peut toujours trouver des
molécules qui dans le passé ont déjà été
vus par jules césar
alors voilà j'ai avec moi un verre d'eau
et vous savez que l'eau est faite de
molécules d'eau h2o deux atomes
d'hydrogène et un atome d'oxygène alors
il faut savoir qu'une molécule d'eau
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très petit puisque ça fait à peu près
0.3 nanomètres ça veut dire que c'est
plus petit que un millionième de
millimètre
c'est pas vraiment très très simple de
se représenter ce que veulent dire
détaille aussi petit
donc notre manière d'y penser c'est de
se demander finalement dans un verre
d'eau comme ça combien de molécules
d'eau alors en fait on peut le calculer
assez facilement
on connaît la masse d'une molécule d'eau
je sais quelle masse d'eau et dans mon
verre donc je peux simplement faire la
division et si on fait ça on trouve que
dans un verre d'à peu près 30 centimes
litre
il ya environ 10 puissance 25 molécules
d'eau 10 puissance 25 c'est vraiment un
chiffre astronomique 1 c'est un suivi de
25,0 par exemple c'est plus que le
nombre de grains de sable sur terre et
tout ça juste dans mon verre d'eau alors
maintenant je voudrais qu'on s'intéresse
à jules césar et en particulier au
dernier verre qu'il a bu juste avant de
se faire assassiner ce dernier verre
s'il était à peu près comme le mien il
contenait lui aussi 10 puissance 25
molécules d'eau la question que je me
pose aujourd'hui c'est parmi ces 10
puissance 25 molécules qui était dans le
dernier verre de césar est-ce que par
chance ils n'auraient pas une qui se
trouverait là aujourd'hui dans mon verre
à moi alors en fait pour estimer ça on
va supposer que toutes les molécules qui
est vers le dernier verre de césar
aujourd'hui elles sont complètement
répandue sur la planète s'est pas
complètement absurde de penser ça parce
qu'il ya le cycle de l'eau les
précipitations et pour un marin et ça
s'est quand même passé il ya deux mille
ans donc on va supposer que toutes ces
molécules du dernier verre de césar
aujourd'hui elles sont complètement
diluée dans les eaux de la planète
mais quelle quantité d'eau il ya sur la
planète alors c'est assez simple à
calculer
je vais pas vous surprendre en vous
disant que la quasi totalité de l'eau de
la planète c'est les mers les océans et
on sait que les mers et les océans font
en moyenne 4,5 km de profondeur et
couvre 70% de la surface du globe
donc si on fait le calcul eh ben on
trouve que sur terre il ya à peu près 10
puissance 21 litres d'eau 10 puissance
21 litres c'est 1000 milliards de
milliards de litres
sauf que tout à l'heure je vous ai dit
que dans le dernier verre de césar il y
avait 10 puissance 25 molécules d'eau
donc si on suppose que ces 10 puissance
25 molécules d'eau aujourd'hui elles
sont complètement diluée dans toute
l'eau de la planète et moi je peux
calculer que en moyenne dans chaque
litre d'eau de la planète
il ya environ dix mille molécules qui se
trouvait dans le dernier verre de césar
10000 molécules par litre d'eau ça veut
dire que dans mon verre à moi qui fais
20 à 30 cm il y aurait à peu près 2000 à
3000 molécules qui se trouvait déjà dans
le dernier verre de césar je sais pas
vous mais moi c'est un bluff
évidemment le raisonnement est pas du
tout spécifique du dernier verre de
césar j'aurais très bien pu prendre
l'avant dernier vers son millième vert
ou même son premier biberon c'était
pareil
évidemment ça marche aussi avec louis
xiv napoléon ça marche même avec le
dernier verre de jésus voilà j'espère
que maintenant que vous savez ça vous
regarderez vous verre d'eau d'un autre
oeil juste avant les boire en pensant à
tous les grands hommes du passé qui s'y
trouvent
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle vous a plu sachez que vous
pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne
c'est la première vidéo mais y en aura
d'autres vous pouvez aussi me retrouver
sur mon blog sciences étonnante ainsi
que sur facebook et sur twitter
à bientôt